am i correct that when you went to
college your first major was journalism
yes I mean that studied journalism for
for a year okay and then I realized that
was as crazy as studying cinema well you
must have been drawn to storytelling
what kind of stories did you think you
would write as a journalist and how did
that transition you into screenwriting
actually it was like just finding way to
fool my parents on my way paying for
college no just to because I belong to a
generation that went back to film
schools after dictatorship so when that
happened Chilean cinema was almost
non-existent
so I just I'm part of that generation
that we had films inside but there
wasn't really an industry and still now
that we have a very fragile industry but
back then it was just insane to un think
of making a film and yeah so journalism
seemed like the closest thing to
filmmaking yeah back then where does
your choice of story come from how did
you arrive at this one well it it's
always hard to answer that because it's
always a intuition you know it's like
you it's like those people that are
looking for water with the wooden sticks
and sometimes they stop and they say
divining right here yeah it's just like
that I mean it's like I don't know like
some point I made three smaller films
mm-hmm before I made a film called
Gloria and and that was my first film
like about a woman like probably proper
woman character study and that opened
like a door in in me and
and I cannot explain it but I've been
very moved and excited and challenged by
this idea of making these films about
women that are somehow I don't know that
can not at the centre of society or
representation or and bring them to the
absolute center and and say you know to
them you you are a film which is the
case in a fantastic woman it's taken
someone that society rejects and bring
her to the absolute center and film her
like doing a love letter to her no
that's the game of the film I feel like
you you see when you write it's like
you're you you see visuals in addition
to writing great words like that's a big
part of the telling the story thank you
thank you I'm very grateful to danila
Vega the the actress I'm so very proud
of her and what she did I'm saying yeah
she's amazing at the beginning she was I
didn't know for what I really wanted to
make the film so it was like exploring
meeting some transgender women and then
they said to me you have to meet
Daniella she's she's she has some acting
experience she's a lyrical singer
student she is fantastic so I met her
and I asked her to be a cultural
consultant mm-hmm and she very
generously accepted so we became friends
and I was I live in in Berlin so Skype
friends and during a year we were like
talking and and I was writing with my
co-writer and suddenly almost without
noticing the script started to absorb
many things that were coming from the
Neela I wondered about like the lyrical
singing
aspect and but at some point in the
writing process and this is related to
your question I stumbled with the idea
of oh why not making making a
transgender film about a transgender
woman and that was like a like wow
that's enough that opened many
possibilities like New Territories and
that's why I'm so grateful because
Taniya was pushing things further and I
was trying to make a script that were
that was as complex and as hopefully
beautiful as she is and and she was
telling challenging me so much and I was
trying to come you know come back with
something complex you know and and
fascinating as she is so at the end of
the process when we had the first draft
I sent it to her and I offered her to
play the main role and and that's how it
happened it was super organic and so I
had no idea that when I met my cultural
consultant I was meeting my my star your
star yeah was she reluctant when you
offered because she obviously you oh
yeah her as the star well she said I did
you go crazy yeah yeah I would you're
nuts and then she went she says that she
went partying and then the next day she
called back and said okay we'll do it I
feel like it has so many things to say
and I'm curious if there's a point that
you would like to make or something that
you would like to say about it but no
one's ever asked you that question not
really because I do believe that films
should be more like a question than like
an answer I truly believe that it like
cinema is a device for asking
not for answer yes so in that sense the
feeling itself is a big question you
know the film itself is a questions
posts the question what is a woman
and to me as a filmmaker it poses the
question what is a film mm-hmm so the
characters identity is being judged and
by everyone and her presence oscillates
all the time in the screen so you are
seeing several things at the same time
is it like a great receptor for your
fantasies fears desires and projections
yes she isolates and the film oscillates
and it it is trans onra yeah yes well
that's what I was trying to express that
in a certain way the film's identity
it's deeply connected with her the
film's own identity is oscillating as
well and doesn't want to be labeled in
one easy gesture ya know it's it's it's
in a certain ways of film against labels
thank you for sharing your film with us
thank you